thanks nate he's a las vegas local who
went on to become a finalist on
america's got talent
and like many performers he was
sidelined but now he is back
earlier today i had the chance to sit
down with the talented daniel emmett
you know him from america's got talent
and
just that voice the voice of an angel
daniel emmett how are you i'm doing
great thank you so much for having me on
the show today
it's so cool to talk to a las vegas
local who has made it big you went to
faith lutheran high school
i mean do you do you get calls from your
old classmates like hey remember me
daniel
well that's that's one thing that's
great about the world we live in is it's
so easy to stay in touch with everyone
i'm very lucky to be rooted in a very
very strong community from where i grew
up here
and i'm very fortunate to still have
roots from where i came from
i've always wanted to know what it's
like for singers when you when you warm
up do you have a warm-up routine
that you do like it's exactly that one
that's that's it right there yes i do i
do a warm routine that i do
every single day before i perform and
just even if i'm not performing just to
make sure that
the cords you know stay in shape it's no
different than somebody
getting ready to do a professional sport
just there's less running involved
can you can you do can you give me a 10
second singing lesson like if i want to
be a singer what's something i could do
to make me sound good
absolutely the most important thing is
breathing
that's where that's where all the
singing comes from it comes from the
breath so you just want to take
a nice deep breath in and it feels like
it feels just like the air is all around
you so you just go
and then you just sing
oh my gosh i'm melting that is beautiful
i'm not gonna even torture people with
that
let's talk about this really cool event
that you have coming up
this is you're you're combining some of
my favorite things you've
it's called sweet notes tell us a little
bit more about it
so sweet notes and you're right it is a
really cool event
it's nathan adelson hospice's very first
virtual fundraising event and normally
you know at this time of year they'd
have their big gala but
it's 20 20 so big in-person events are
not in vogue right now
but this way we're going to combine as
you said some of your favorite things
wine chocolate and music while you get
to stay in the comfort of your own home
sit back and relax and enjoy this
interactive virtual experience with
a wine and chocolate pairing from
world-class sommelier harley carberry
and chocolatier daylene coleman i'm
really proud to play a small
part in this jam-packed hour of fun
we're doing a special one-of-a-kind mini
concert
made just for sweet notes and on top of
all that there's also a special
appearance by a friend of nathan allison
hospice brad garrett
so it's a lot going on from 6 to 7 p.m
on thursday
okay so how do people get tickets to the
event
so people can get tickets by going to
nah.org
and that's the way easy as that you get
chocolate you get
wine and it's like you go and you pick
this up and then you get to listen to
you
going
it was great
we're so proud of you daniel and can't
wait to see it if you need more
information we are going to have it on
our website
one more time for good measure please
sure
i'll see you soon
[Music]
wow that voice right oh my gosh he's
amazing give mercedes give it live on tv
right now give it to us one more time
give it to us oh you got to give it to
me afterwards i'll
oh no that was about you you try you try
oh man we have some work to do
how about we do the wine and we do the
chocolates everyone's a great singer
after they drink some wine and have some
chocolates we're all
we're all amazing singers well